shutting down the red carpet here the
producers guild awards but last woman
standing you know what also woman
standing up in a lot of amazing projects
big little lies bombshell we just wanted
to ask you having accomplished
everything that you have with these
projects what advice would you give to
young women who are starting out in
acting in producing on how they can kind
of follow this path that you've been on
I mean I think it's just absolute
commitment - for me it's the commitment
initially to the craft and the art of
acting which I still have the passion
for in' that i love and then being able
to collaborate and be a part of the
group because whoever you choose to be
around and work with you're only as good
as the people that you're working with I
feel like I still never lose the love of
it I've just literally come from
shooting on set on the prom where I'm
doing a musical tonight which is why I
was like quick get dressed put some
lippy on and rights to this to come I am
but I wasn't singing today I was just
getting to sort of watch James Corden
and Meryl Streep do their thing what's
it like to be sharing the screen with
Meryl gamba also you know ariana grande
no she's not she's not in it a lot of
stars I can't keep track of the prom and
you said you would like to revisit your
character from rulon Rouge so now you're
singing again
yeah well I'm singing a fantastic number
called zazz in this which is from the
Broadway production that was just on
Broadway so we have to ask you will you
revisit big little lies every fans want
to know you didn't Reese make it did she
make it here we have not seen her yet
well what's gonna - it was like I'm
rushing everybody what would it take it
would take great story you know so
that's what we're gonna see if we can do
but right now it's um
it's certainly more of a dream than it
is a reality sorry to say but maybe one
day I see a sign saying wrap it
Nicole Kidman knows those cues get enjoy
[Music]